hey what's up guys my name is cube and
you probably see me in a couple BuzzFeed
videos it's laughing having a good time
being really goofy but one thing people
don't know about me is that I'm actually
very shy so growing up I had two
brothers and we were so closely knit
they were my best friends and I stare
are to this day when I was growing up I
didn't really feel the need to get out
and have to meet new friends and do all
this other stuff most people do so what
I'm gonna do now is challenge myself to
go out of the country and really get out
of my comfort zone so it's gonna be
seven days I set challenges for myself
and I have to complete them challenge
number one is gonna be that to go out
and grab food with somebody so challenge
number two we're just working out with
somebody if I'm working out if I'm being
active I'm gonna be myself fully number
three is to go out on an adventure
Thailand is full of so many things you
can do from parties and going out on
boats so going out on an adventure and
really exploring the city with Google
people number four is going to be doing
something that I've never done before
but yeah this is gonna be interesting
I'm really excited okay so the first
step I had to do was get home pack my
stuff and mentally prepare myself for
this 19 hours worth of traveling I had
to do so my plan out in Thailand was to
go to a social hotel called love D where
I knew I'd be able to meet people make
friends and just become more social I'm
like Andrews we're here love de pétanque
so a social hotel is in the best part of
a four-star resort and drop them into
essentially what a backpackers is a big
part of a social hotel obviously is the
ability to have you know every traveler
not only come and enjoy the facilities
but come and engage the ability to meet
someone face to face and actually have a
conversation and do something with them
it is getting harder and harder and
we're getting you know more disconnected
so what we wanted to try and create with
love D was you know an environment and
an atmosphere of you know everyone's
welcome and everyone leads to friends
looks like it's a party already going
down alright guys so today is my first
official day in Lodi I got in last night
around like 7 or 8 o'clock or something
like that after a long day of trial then
I was really tired so today I'm just
gonna keep it simple just uh meet up
with some people have some food I think
is a pretty simple go to have a starter
right now
[Music]
[Music]
all right so do deliveries it's not a
dog I made some of the cashmere playing
boy we just tell I'll do some work then
after that I'll probably head out some
do hope I mean a little bit of people
later 2,000 years later all right so um
update it's currently about to be 11:00
p.m. here in Thailand so pretty much
after breakfast now came up to getting a
shower to go back out and I ended up
laying down I take a nap and about 10 11
12 hours later I'm just not good enough
but the good thing about love DS I even
though it's 11:00 p.m. here it's still
going down and that's why we're really
good chancing me some people some go
right down here right now and see what I
can do to try to complete challenge one
on day one honestly I am so glad I
decided to come back downstairs after
that long nap there was a group from
Mexico enjoying the music
and it was really organic I didn't have
to go out of my way I just introduced
myself and it felt so good to do that so
day two my challenge was to just meet
some people to go workout with and I
knew going into it that it was gonna be
super awkward but I would have never
imagined it was as awkward as it was it
was definitely a test of how serious I
was about doing this hey man you are you
down to do a quick workout we're doing I
got some run in we'll do a little bit of
boxing but
it'll be nice you don't let's do it
hey man we're doing a workout if you
want to be a part of it
he's my flip-flop to death no okay okay
yo guys I'm doing a quick little work on
you guys you're down to join me mote I
do a little running the little box in
should be dope
so we got a good mind people to join the
workout now it's time we go
you got like eight or nine people I was
a pretty good turnout though the most
difficult thing about this challenge was
actually finding the people to come work
out with me once we got into the workout
I was in my comfort zone so we started
out with a couple runs then we got right
into doing some push-ups and then we got
into the Thai boxing and there was a lot
of moving pieces that I've never done
before but it was probably the most fun
I have when I was there
[Music]
[Music]
I'm not even gonna lie like I was out
there struggling but when it came down
to actually boxing and put in the work I
really was out there looking like a mix
between like Floyd Mayweather and
probably a little bit of Conor McGregor
[Music]
shada got some people to come home
so we're go fun
really can't be good you know thanks for
another
it's reggaeton I really can't say too
much about day 2 besides it was hard
work getting people there it was hard
work working out but overall it was all
worth it
day two was complete and I accomplished
my goal to actually have a workout with
somebody it was very fulfilling to get
this done because it took a lot for me
to actually go out and reach out to
people and put myself in a position to
like get turned down day three I did not
have a lot going on so I felt like this
would be a good time for me to go on an
adventure like explore Thailand and
luckily I met some guys before who were
going on a trip to PP islands and
honestly it was one of the best
experience out of my life I mean if it
was anybody I should ever meet on this
trip it was these guys these guys were
so impressive I'm talking about multiple
language very sociable and just overall
great people honestly if you've never
been on a boat trip in open water with
like mountains around you I promise you
you are missing out on something amazing
it was for Walker for the juice the
first time we stopped on had a bunch of
random cats running around it was just
really random but it was amazing like we
just got to play with some cats while we
ate our food so it was really cool so
what we were doing with stop
and Alan's seeing different things and
we stay for a little bit and then we're
out so once we left the first island we
went over to go snorkeling because I
realized that swimming in like a pool
versus swimming in the ocean is
completely different I had to hand over
the GoPro to my friend bunky he took it
from there so about halfway through our
snorkeling trip it started raining on us
so hard I'm talking about rain that I've
never seen before just as quickly as it
started to come down it went away and it
was beautiful again I would definitely
say the best part of this trip was going
over to Monkey Island and being able to
actually feed animals I'm standing in
the middle of the ocean reaching up to a
Moen and there's monkeys coming down
trying to it was really one of the
craziest things I've ever done in my
life and then another one came up to my
friend and climbed up his shirt to grab
the food out of his hand it was really
crazy it was just really amazing to be
there so day 4 I wasn't sure what I was
gonna be doing but I just happen to run
across the opportunity to go hang out
with a group who was going to do some
leg surfing and that's something I've
never done before so I figured like hey
why not I would just go out here and
just do it and see what happens honestly
I don't even want to say too much about
this trip I just want you guys to see
exactly what I was doing and I'll let
you be the judge
[Music]
so Beckett loved D I ran into a group of
guys we just wanted to go grab some food
it just so happened that right up the
street was a spot cost surf house baton
and it is nuts you get up there you
absolutely fell it took me about a good
like three to four tries before I really
got it but that's my different kwazy
always says I was failing upward and it
was felling up we're in the best way I
had Mike I had curse for me and we were
just having a good time and I would have
to say it was a hundred percent the most
exhilarating day of the trip well I
guess I should say it was the most
exhilarating
Peto day five it was almost like having
said that I met Matt and Tyler who were
also down here in Thailand filming they
were also from Canada just like Chris
and Mike it was just like a coincidence
but we put yourself out there to have
fun these are the type of things that
can happen and it was really just hi
opening to see
[Music]